check the mic and make sure it sounds
right boy hello how much of a fan of the
vision transformers are you are you
happy how transformers initially
introduced for text took over the state
of the art in image classification or
are you nostalgically looking back to
convolutional neural networks miss
coffeebean do not come here with the
nostalgia argument convnets and their
priors are still very much the kings of
their own hill look the swing
transformers which are transformers at
their core do a lot of gymnastics to
introduce a hierarchical processing in
transformers hierarchical design that
convunets always had if transformers
want to solve not only holistic tasks
like image classification but object
detection and semantic segmentation
where attention to detail is required
attention no pun intended so if they
want to solve these tasks transformers
need to process smaller patches than 16
by 16 pixels like convenience do
so how to compare convlets and
transformers and make it fair sometimes
transformers steal from convnets i'm
looking at use when transformer with
your hierarchical processing and the
credit for the performance gain goes to
the transformer but what about reversing
the rolls letting a convnet steal from a
transformer how many things do we have
to add to a convnet to make it as
powerful as a transformer well if you're
interested in this question you're in
luck what if me and miss coffee bean
told you that there is a paper which
takes a standard convolutional neural
net a resnet and morphs it such that the
design approaches a vision transformer
in spoiler it surpasses the transformer
in terms of performance hey miss coffee
bean is spoiling the surprise here so
let's stop her and introduce our sponsor
for today's video thanks to weights and
biases for supporting me and this little
coffee bean over here you do not know
who they are weights and biases is an ml
ops platform helping you and your team
to improve and accelerate the process of
building and maintaining machine
learning models do you want to track
experiments to save your model
configuration so you can reproduce even
that model which you stashed away months
ago which you now maybe want to
reproduce but cannot remember its
settings weights and vices has got you
covered on that front
are you training a model and want to
find the right hyper parameter
configurations but it seems more like
alchemy than science to you then let
weights and biases sweeps functionality
find the optimal parameters for you
during your lunch break
don't worry weights and biases is not
hard to integrate it just needs a few
lines of code and the best bit is yet to
come this is all for free if it's meant
for personal use or for academic themes
so what are you waiting for check out
weights and biases
now let's get back to today's paper
making confnets fashionable again for
the 2020s with this paper we witnessed
how a convolutional neural net or short
a conv net steals modern training tricks
that transformers usually benefit from
to build the ultimate convnext
architecture this
convnext is super interesting because by
modernizing convnets step by step one
can better see where performance can be
gained like is it more the architecture
is it more the training tricks is it
more
i don't know crazy design choices and
convnexs are competitive with
transformers not only in image
classification but
also on object detection and image
segmentation where the swin transformer
had its reign so far then let's follow
the paper and see
what is it that convnets have that is so
precious and we should keep it even in
the era where transformers take over
everything
which steps do the authors take to
modernize convnets into convnexts and
what are the associated performance
gains what can we learn from all of this
feel free to jump around in the video to
watch the parts you are most interested
in also note that some of the concepts
we touch upon we will explain only
briefly but others are left a bit
unexplained as they would deserve a
video on their own
so it's convenient versus transformers
today the authors introduced the paper
by praising convnets miss coffee bean
how else their agenda is to resurrect
the idea of convolutional networks so
the authors start of course by
mentioning how the deep learning
renaissance was driven by convnets in
2012
the introduction of alexnet established
the imagenet moment in computer vision
and visual recognition turned from
feature engineering to designing convnet
architectures that learn their own
features like vggnet inceptions resnet
densnet mobilenet efficient netragnet
what do all of these networks have in
common well the convolution a sliding
window that processes the visual input
in the same manner so the parameters are
shared between image locations this is a
big plus when bounded by computation
convolutions also induce translation
echivarians are you not sure what this
means and why the authors use the word
equivalence and not invariants well then
let miss coffee beans past self explain
this in 60 seconds to you we have an
interesting question on our quiz where
the majority was wrong it's about
convolutions and the difference between
invariance and achy variance
translational or shift invariance means
that irrespectively of the position of a
cat the output of the convolution
operation is the same which it isn't
since the feature map still reflects the
original position so this is actually
echi variance because when the position
of the cat changes the output changes in
the same way reflecting shift and with
the sliding kernel this is exactly what
happens so convolutions are not shift
invariant but ecky variant if you got
this wrong it's okay because these words
are used interchangeably in language
except of highly mathematical contexts
please mind that the question asks about
the convolution only it was a next day's
trick question inquiring about the cnn
as a whole while convolutional layers do
not make the cnn shift invariant but
only eki variant it takes spatial
pooling layers to make it approximately
shift invariant by pushing information
that was far away into approximately the
same spot okay we got it convolutions
are great but what about transformers
well after the introduction of
transformers for text processing in 2017
the transformer actually had some
applications on image generation or
image text understanding applications
which went widely unnoticed so unnoticed
that today's paper like almost any other
paper does not mention this the
transformer architecture got properly
noticed by the computer vision community
when
of course when it was proven to advance
the state of the art on imagenet okay
then what is so cool about transformers
first the transformers as we know it
from natural language processing or
short nlp is more or less usable out of
the box for images exception is recite
the initial patchify layer which splits
an image into a sequence of patches of
for example 16 by 16 pixels and there we
have it the vit watch our previous
videos on this for context vit's scaling
laws allows to increase the model size
and the size of the training data and it
overcomes resonance but vit's problems
are just around the corner without the
inductive bias introduced by sliding
windows the solution space of
transformers is larger than for cnns
just imagine a cnn by construction
cannot converge to anything that is not
translational echivariant but a
transformer very well can because it
misses this guiding bias this is what we
mean when we say the solution space of
transformers is larger the architecture
is more flexible because the solution
space is larger
therefore in the case where there is
little training data to find the right
solution in this bigger space
transformers are dependent on a lot of
training tricks like heavy data
augmentation as we have seen with deit
but the biggest problem that
transformers have is everything but
imagenet scenarios so cases where the
images are high resolution and the
prediction must be dense in this case
patchifying into 16 by 16 pixels might
be too coarse to make right pixel level
predictions but if we were to make the
patches smaller this would quadratically
increase the sequence length because we
would need more of these patches to
cover the same surface and we know that
when we increase the sequence lengths
for transformers the compute and memory
footprint increases again quadratically
to overcome this hierarchical
transformers such as the swin
transformer introduce sliding windows
again which makes them resemble very
much with convnets in this aspect noting
this the authors cannot help but ask
themselves what if they would morph a
convent towards a swin transformer what
would we see from this interpolation to
answer the question we cite how do
design decisions in transformers impact
convnet's performance and imagine the
authors wanted to know the answer to
this so badly that they run the
according experiments and write a paper
about this then let's follow their steps
of modernizing convents to make them
stylish enough for the 2020s since the
style of the 2020s is definitely given
by transformers we mean that the authors
make confidence more transformer-like so
step one take a resonate 50. the authors
also have experimented with the larger
resnet 200 but if you want to know about
that read the paper more specifically
appendix c
you should always anyway read the paper
yourself and you should not trust a phd
student in her coffee bean to tell you
everything there is to know about a
paper or should you
okay we have taken a resnet 50 now what
about it well first and above all the
authors train it with similar training
techniques as vision transformers are
trained with they use the admw optimizer
use more epochs heavy data augmentation
regularization
all of this increased the performance of
the resnet 50 from
76.1 percent to 78.8 percent on imagenet
top one accuracy so wow lesson learned i
will not forget about these ingredients
when baking my cnn base models the
second thing they modernize after they
are done with including the training
techniques is something the authors call
the macro design of the resnet for the
stage ratio they adjust the number of
blocks in each stage and improve model
accuracy then they make the sliding
windows in the resnet behave more like
the patches in vision transformers so
with a larger kernel size and with a
stride such that the sliding window does
not overlap this looks already much more
like the non-overlapping patches in the
transformer this again increases
performance if only by a little bit the
third stage adopts the idea that res
next
had introduced before
namely the idea of inception if you're
old enough to remember that of splitting
transforming and merging information the
key word here is depth-wise convolutions
a special case of grouped convolutions
where the number of groups equals the
number of channels
important to note and he recites from
the paper is that depth-wise convolution
is similar to the weighted sum
operations of attention which operates
on a per channel basis that is only
mixing information in the spatial
dimension end quote and depth-wise
convolutions having reduced the number
of flops also reduce the accuracy but by
simultaneously widening the network the
performance is substantially improved
it's time for the fourth stage of the
whole improvement process which is the
so-called inverted bottlenecks we find
it a little bit misleading here that the
authors say that one important design in
every transformer block is that it
creates an inverted bottleneck that is
the hidden dimension of the mlp block is
four times wider than the input
dimension
hopefully we don't get something wrong
here but this is the case for every swin
transformer in particular not every
transformer in general because yes in
swin transformers that work
hierarchically the outputs of four
blocks get concatenated such that in the
end the hidden dimension increases four
times but
in any case they
they want to copy this idea by using a
we quote inverted bottleneck design with
an expansion ratio of four used in
convenience
in hooray this increases performance too
if only by a little
the fifth stage introduces larger kernel
sizes this tries to equal the power of
vision transformers that have a global
receptive field and see the image at
once through self-attention that spans
the whole image but swin transformers
limit the self-attention window so if
the authors increase the resnet's window
size then they should reach the same
compromise this results in an increase
in performance of
nothing but it's clear that small kernel
sizes hurt the performance and finally
the sixth and final stage comes with
micro design choices such as replacing
the rectified linear unit activation
function with the gaussian error linear
unit used in bird or gpt2 or vit
they are using the activation functions
less often as transformers also do in
the mlp block only and with the same
motivation to do everything more
transformer style the authors also use
fewer normalization layers because
transformers use them less often than
the resnet as well they are replacing
batch normalization with layer
normalization short reminder in batch
norm a mini batch of data that has
multiple examples and features
associated to it
the normalization happens across the
batch or sample dimension the batch
normalization effect is that the
magnitude of the features is similar
across data samples in the batch layer
norm normalizes across the feature
dimension such that per data sample the
features have around the same magnitude
historically layer norm was something
that worked better for recurrent neural
networks whereas batch norm was mostly
used in convenience in surprise all
these micro modifications have a
tremendous impact on performance and by
using separate down sampling layers this
enhanced resnet achieves an accuracy of
82.0
imagenet top 1 accuracy exceeding the
swin transformer and these results are
comparable because the swin transformer
plays in the same league in terms of
computation and size if you're curious
to know how this fares in the big model
league you just have to look at the gray
bars in the figure where they start from
a resnet 200 and add all these steps
with similar gains okay cool we have
seen steady performance increase and
really impressive numbers and results
but what are the lessons here with
respect to our confident versus
transformer boxing match so the first
lesson here is that not only
transformers but modernized convnets
scale too in terms of size and data and
we have not discussed the data aspect i
know check out the additional
experiments with more data in the paper
the second lesson is related to the
tasks convnets can compete in object
detection and semantic segmentation with
the swin transformer which we remember
was a hierarchical version of vit
maybe you are wondering what exactly the
novelty of this paper is well we cite it
is also worth noting that none of the
design options discussed thus far is
novel they have all been researched
separately but not collectively over the
last decade and while the authors here
are genuine convolution advocates by
reading this paper we must ask ourselves
what if the bigger lesson of this paper
applies to other architectures too what
if while everyone in nlp suddenly jumped
onto the next stage dominated by
transformers forgot to stepwise improve
rnn's or their tree rnns or everything
that is not fashionable anymore so far
we thought that self-attention and the
way that transformers process
information in parallel highways is the
recipe for success
but this paper suggests that it is
rather the many seemingly tiny
architecture hyper parameters and not
the architecture itself that can tweak
the way to state of the art another
thing we wonder and this is maybe
something only the authors can answer is
whether the experiments were really
conducted in the order presented in the
paper and in this figure here it is more
plausible that these design choices were
added in all possible orders and
configurations and that the authors
picked and presented everything where
improvement over improvement can be seen
don't get us wrong we do not criticize
the paper with this miss coffee bean
just wants to warn me that science is
not always this straightforward
ascending line to the finish and coming
back to the contribution and to the
novelty of this paper even though no
design option was presented it is the
art of putting everything together or
rather the power of brute forcing every
available option that makes this paper
bear the fruits it does and maybe a tiny
critique that almost any paper in
machine learning deserves
let's not forget that papers do the
comparisons they like and suit them best
miss coffee bean will leave you to this
tweet also linked in the description
below where one of the vit authors
points out that convnex were compared
only to playing vit while swin and
convnex had heavy augmentation
judge for yourself but also do not
forget to count the number of times you
took the baselines you liked the most
miss coffeebeans stop teasing our
audience let's rather talk about how we
reached 10 000 subscribers this
christmas celebration video when miss
coffee bean miss coffee bean come back
hey don't leave us hanging here
okay bye
[Music]
it sound right boy